o intuitively, anyone with common sense knows that
rallies with thousands of people crowded together,
mostly without masks, aren't a good
idea. During a global 100 year pandemic,
most people understand that.
And especially as we get into spike
number three of the virus in the United States,
you would be extra aware of the fact that that's
a bad idea. But Donald Trump has continued to do
the rallies. And we now have a new analysis from
Stanford University which found that looking at 18
Trump rallies specific, there's way more than 18.
But looking at just 18 those 18 rallies and you
can get the exact list and looking at the study
were responsible for roughly 30000
cases of corona virus and 700 deaths.
The study is called the effects of large group
meetings on the spread of KOVA 19. The case of
Trump rallies. Now, what is really important
to understand is, well, two things. Number one,
this only looked at 18 rallies. So the
total number is, of course, much higher.
But the other element of this is that when
they say these 18 rallies led to 700 deaths.
The important caveat is not necessarily
among rally attendees. In other words.
It's not just about you.
If you want to take the risk of going
and you were the only person at risk, that
would be one thing. As Vox notes, a rally goer
may become infected with a mild case, but the same
rally goer gives the virus to their wife or their
parent, who gives it to a coworker, to sister
and then to grandma who dies of corona virus.
The deaths also are people who are getting
the virus despite not having been at the
rallies. If it were as simple as 700 of
the people who went to the rallies died,
it's tragic. But at least it's people choosing
to be there who are dying. This is people in the
community because it's a virus and that's how
it spreads. And you might think, by the way,
that killing your own supporters is a
bad idea and you'd be right. But again,
presumably some of the people dying as a result
of the rallies aren't even Trump's supporters,
although people do tend to live in ideologically
similar groups as a general rule up. And the
reality is the election is not going to come down
to 700 people. And meanwhile, Trump ridicules Joe
Biden for wearing a mask and having safe drive
in rallies where people sit in their cars.
It's not just incompetence, it's immorality.
And it's a complete disregard for human life.
Often when we say disregard for human life, it's a
metaphor for its hyperbolic. It's an exaggeration.
This time it's not. It's it's just literal
disregard for human life. Seven hundred people
died as a result of 18 Trump rallies. And
Trump is holding five more rallies today.
It's extremely difficult.
For me to even understand.
How Donald Trump is even competitive in this
election, like I understand specifically,
he lies and people fall for it. And he played
on racial animus from the Obama era. You know,
all this stuff together, people fear, fear of
losing status, all of this. But in terms of how
frightening it is for our country, how badly
it bodes for the future of the United States,
even just looking at this rally example, I
mean, they they claim to be pro-life. Trump
claims to be the most pro-life president
ever. But standing around to see Trump is
worth passing along the virus and killing
people. How pro-life is that? Not very. And
unfortunately, I we're at the end of the game.
Right. Unfortunately, there's a reasonable chance
that we have four more years of this. And if
that's the case, we will have much to discuss and
figure out. Either way, we'll have much to discuss
and figure out, including what happens to 60
million Trump ists if Biden wins. But they still
live in the country. We'll talk about all of that.